[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
where's that beard John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast about death where two
brothers answer you questions give you
beasts advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how are you doing John
I'm doing well we're in the same place
like this is a real-life podcast
recording yeah we're in a hotel in
Chicago
nerville and we are recording the
podcast live in person while in the
background I think the movie Hotel
Transylvania is playing you just keep us
up-to-date on what's happening cuz I
can't see it oh don't worry events are
occurring since we last potted Hank my
new book Turtles all the way down was
published yes it happened and and I'm so
grateful to you for taking a month away
from your life to tour with the book and
week away from the pot I'm sorry that we
didn't get an episode we did I'm sorry
too because I that meant one week where
I wasn't able to share reviews of the
book but don't worry I'm going to share
them now
oh is that what the whole podcast is
gonna be no not the whole podcast just
the first 40 minutes then we'll get to
questions from our listeners I hope you
guys like the book thanks to everybody
who pre-ordered it and and everybody who
is reading it now I'm so grateful and
overwhelmed and also still somewhat
afraid about this whole thing but the
New York Times did call it wrenching and
revelatory in the Wall Street Journal
called it tender wise and hopeful there
were really lovely reviews all around
the Guardian said it might might be a
modern classic The Globe and Mail said
that I didn't create a book so much as a
place a place to have your most
indefinable and grotesque thoughts
articulated I'm not sure if that's a
compliment but I like it yeah I feel
like I should be reading these because
it sounds more authentic coming from
from me rather than from you but it's
already happened yeah but there's no
going what did what did Vox call it not
not so much teen romances and as a
existential teenage scream yeah that was
guy like that one a lot yeah well we're
not quoting from the bad reviews but
they've only been a couple of those to
be fair yeah
can I read to you some of my one-star
amazon reviews please oh man this should
be a whole podcast just talking to
authors about their one-star amla amazon
reviews all right are you ready Hank
uh-huh
one star just to be clear my copy was
stolen and I haven't read it yet
thank you thank you for leaving that one
start oh my god that's it that's the
whole thing that's not this one star
review are you ready uh-huh so far
there's only I'm encouraging more of
these but there's only four one-star
reviews the book 90% five and four-star
reviews but the okay that my favorite
one-star review is that's gonna be a no
for me from Jacqueline whose entire
review I'm gonna read it to you right
now this is the review in its entirety
not F Scott I think the jacqueline means
that I'm not f scott Fitzgerald in which
case like I strongly agree uh-huh and
also if you thought that you were
getting the Great Gatsby
it's a one-star book yeah well the thing
is the greats get the Great Gatsby is
available like you could get it you've
it but but but f scott Fitzgerald
little-known facts not currently writing
not available unavailable for future
engagements from now until the end of
the human species in eight weeks let's
get to some questions from our listeners
questions from Haley who has no short
poem for us no dear Hank and John I am a
young writer and I really love writing
stories and essays and all that stuff
but I hate letting other people read my
work I hate sharing it yeah I can relate
Haley I feel like I'm giving tiny pieces
of my soul to everyone who looks at my
writing and that didn't turn out well
for Voldemort well I mean it turned out
okay for him he didn't date better than
all the more than if he had kept a soul
in one play it's true yes I think you
might have misread the book Haley well
and we're not encouraging fracturing
your soul and placing it inside of
objects through murder but it yeah just
like just like drinking blue unicorn
blood it will keep you alive it's a
strategy so please
how do I get comfortable sharing my
stories with other people and a dubious
advice is greatly appreciated it's not
rainy it's not snowy it's hailey
oh that's a great name specific sign-off
hailey here's the thing you don't have
to get comfortable with it if you don't
want to you don't have to share your
work but the fact that you're asking the
question makes me think that you want on
some level to share your work but you
also are terrified of responses to it
and it does feel like you feel very I
mean I well I won't speak for you hailey
I feel very exposed with this book in
particular but with all of my books like
I feel very exposed when the book first
comes out and very scared and very much
like you know I am available for
criticism that would eviscerate me and
it would be hard for me not to let that
hit me in the deepest parts of myself
and and that should be the case because
what you're writing or what you're
working on in your life like it should
matter to you and so pause you know so
you should want to make it for people as
a gift if you if you want to write for
an audience and it is sad if people
don't accept the gift or if they don't
like it it's a bummer
um but also I guess just two things
first off you make it as a gift and like
a good gift you're not looking for
somebody to say like oh I loved this
because you didn't make it for them to
love it you made it as a gift and you
did your best and as long as you can say
that I think you're in the clear and
secondly your life is not your work and
you're gonna be okay even if people
don't like your writing which by the way
they probably will yeah you got a share
or else you you you will be your only
reader and I like and and you will be
the only person giving you any feedback
and that is not how to grow as a as a
creator if you want to if you want to be
growing yeah I mean part of how you get
better is by negative feedback as
uncomfortable as that is and I think
I've actually benefited a lot from
negative feedback to my books in the
past and to some extent already from
this book so I think you've got to
listen and but it is hard I don't know
minimize how hard it is because it is
hard this question comes from Hannah who
writes dear green brothers I've made a
horrible mistake I like a lady so we
were texting she's very sweet and nice
and I've known her for years but we just
started texting yesterday I was telling
my friend about her and my mushy
feelings when I looked down on an iPhone
you can take voice memos by pressing
down and they send where you let go I
have sent this memo to her it is of my
voice saying my mushy feelings for her
she has not responded and I am very
scared more winking omnia that means
love conquers all Hannah do you know
what oh man
in the in the quote what comes after
love conquers all what let me read it
from the inside of my wedding ring Dork
at no pseudonymous am worried but and so
we shall yield to it ah oh yeah that's
good stuff
Hannah you seem to have found yourself
in the plot of a romantic comedy
the good news Hannah is that one day
you're going to be able to mine this for
a great story the bad news is you're
gonna have to burn this sucker to the
ground walk away and never speak to this
person every I mean you just got to look
around and like a Zach Braff they're
like are you yeah I get like are you at
a bar with all of your buds
we're like huh I feel anxious just
answering this question honestly I mean
so here's here's what I think I think
that there's a great chance that this
voice member was unintelligible because
every time I get a butt-dial I'm like
what are they saying I don't know when I
hang up so it's good good chance that it
was just rustling noises and the person
was like oh and clearly it's a butt-dial
so I think possibly if that were the
case I think you would have gotten a
reply text that was like I think you
butt-dialed
me I don't think that you would have
gotten no reply at all I think the no
reply at all I don't want to but may
isn't it like maybe a cute little origin
story for their fledgling relations
here's the other thing Hank it's been
seven weeks since Santa sent this email
so I think but when this happens again
yes in a future episode of How I Met
Your Mother oh yeah I think what it
happens to you my feeling is you gotta
go aggressively you've got to
immediately say that was an accident
yeah I am really sorry so this happened
to me once
yeah with a TV network that will go
unnamed ready yes they sent Hank and I
an offer to be on their new TV network
to be a TV stars on their TV network and
you know Hank and I didn't know much
about Hollywood then and we thought the
offer would be for a lot of money and it
would be tempting we were still gonna
say no but we thought it would be
difficult
instead the offer was for what I would
what I would describe I feel like I
can't be specific for legal reasons but
I would describe it as low four figures
and I replied I thought - Hank
saying this is ridiculous I wouldn't do
it for a hundred times that and I did
not reply just a Hank I replied to
everyone and they said okay kind of they
were like well let's talk about that and
I was just like no you're like if you
are the kind of person who can offer
that amount while having the flexibility
up to that other amount I feel already
very manipulated by I'm not good we
already can't work together just basic
under like
the the range of your negotiating yes
unacceptable - yes clearly if you are
willing to pay that much you shouldn't
have otter offered the other number this
next question comes from Georgia who
asks dear Ginza for having talked about
that at all like I'm a jerk for for
turning down any money I really enjoy
candles this is from Georgia yeah I
usually burn a lavender candle while I'm
studying to attempt to release myself
from the prison of stress that
constantly surrounds me I'm confused
to this I am confused as to this where
does all the wax go is the wax somehow
evaporating I didn't think that that
could happen and if it does what happens
when it condenses is there a thin layer
of wax on the ceiling of my study or is
it just floating in the air and now my
study is 97% candle how the candles even
work help me candles and coffee Georgia
Georgia green candles in coffee Georgia
first of all you have a study that's
awesome
that's great congratulations yeah I'm
she's included a picture of her candle
and it's it's clearly decreased in
candle nests
think I don't know the answer to his
question because I think the last time I
intentionally lit a candle was during my
first French kiss you like you are
currently like you had a tongue in
someone else's mouth and a lighter on a
candle no I lit the candle it was the
last day of camp you've heard this story
oh yeah and I wrap my arms around my
girlfriend and my hair caught on fire my
hair burned I mean that candle like
there's this ceremony at that summer
camp it's like everybody gets candles
you sing a song and then everybody helps
each other which is just like lighting
each other on fire the only thing that
happens the entire summer camp smells
like burnt hair yeah my first everytime
why do they keep doing this well I mean
they probably don't me they probably
stomped you right now these days what do
they probably use like just iPhone
yeah iPhone flashlights yeah yeah the
answer your question Georgia and I'm
gonna answer this non scientifically and
then Hanks gonna answer it
scientifically the answer your question
is that the wax goes to heaven yeah
that's where it lives down so candles
are made up of like a fuel so that
paraffin is a you know it's a fossil
fuel at this point probably is where it
came from
sometimes it comes from bees but usually
it comes from it's like extracted from
oil and it burns just like any other
fuel it turns into carbon dioxide in
water for the most part and so it is it
is the wax of the candle that is burning
so in the same way when you burn a log
like the log goes away because it turns
into gas when you burn a candle it goes
away because it turns into gas that's
what's that cool it's pretty cool I was
very confused about that myself at one
point and then I was like I thought that
like the candle existed to like keep the
wick from burning that's what I thought
yeah but no the week is there to bring
the the liquid paraffin up to the flame
this question comes from Jamison who
writes Dear John Hanke every day I ride
the bus to school and every day I sit in
the exact same seat it's the perfect
seat right at the front so I don't need
to walk a long way I'm first off the bus
I'm on the right hand side so I don't
make awkward eye contact with the bus
driver in their large rear view mirror
and I'm away from all the noisy kids in
the back I couldn't ask for a better
seat at 7 o'clock in the morning Jesus
Christ Jameson they make you good school
at 7 o'clock in the morning ha ha this
is a prison camp good god that's what
I'm into school it's a form of torture
it's terrible
who wants to warn anything at 7 o'clock
in the morning let alone calculus it is
not a good system
oh it's not a good system dumb ik like
there's lots of research that's like
this is a bad thing especially and
research tonight wait I've been a
teenager who woke up at 7 o'clock in the
morning once yeah
teenagers have delayed like like there's
a thing that happens when you reach you
know your teenage years is you start
like it's naturally staying up later and
getting up later and we do the opposite
to them in school it's it's a thing that
I'd like looked at it's like
legitimately upsetting there's lots of
like sort of structural logistical
reasons why we do it but it's very bad
for actual education I mean then I would
argue the structural reasons aren't that
good right well not right anyway
that's not Jameson's question for the
last couple days my seat has been taken
over by other kids on the bus I know
they probably have no ill intent but you
can't just switch where you sit one day
they see me roll and I'm hey mmm
Jameson thanks I know thank you for
doing that you can just switch where you
set Jameson unfortunately yeah there is
no rule about minutes to sit we're on
the bus now I mean you had a good seat
for a long time and now you don't
anymore like you could go like you're
just your your where you are on the bus
route you have to pick a seat from the
available seat I would say maybe you can
go to the people who are sitting there
now and you can say listen is this
something that is a big deal for you
because it is kind of a big deal for me
now it's not a while since I was a high
school I do not make that suggestion I
didn't crush it as a high school thing
and that might be part of why you and
you have to do you have so you have to
deal with this and you have to deal with
it at seven o'clock in the morning when
no one no one on the bus wants to be
awake everybody is just awake and hating
it all right I think this question comes
from chin who writes Dear John and Hank
do you think if you tell someone you
love them again and again enough times
it loses its meaning does it matter if
you say it when you aren't actually
feeling love for them in that moment
specifically but you know you love them
present tense not just then but all the
time I'm not very good at words but I
hope you get what I mean
pumpkins and hang on this chin I think
you explained that really well I think
you are really good at words you think
you're underselling yourself here's the
thing I do not believe that love is a
feeling tell me more wives sir
so when I was doing my Catholic engaged
encounter in two days I mean it the most
important is seriously he brings up the
Catholic engaged encounter with me more
than anything and I'm not saying that
there's anything wrong with that that's
great and like maybe we should all be
doing this Catholic engagement like at
least I think everybody should have two
days where they like are forced to talk
with the people they love about stuff
yeah right I agree so I Sarah and I when
we were engaged we did this two-day
Catholic engage encounter I did not want
to do
at all I begged Sara when we were in the
parking lot of the monastery to just
skip it this was stupid monastery oh
yeah well I had to bunk with strangers
were there monks yes
there was a stressful situation I'm not
Catholic I don't know a lot about
Catholicism and it was a stressful
situation however it was incredibly
helpful because they asked us big
questions that we had to write essays
back about - back and forth to each
other they will read however many years
later anyway I at the Catholic engage
encounter they told us that love is a
feeling but it is also a decision mm-hmm
and to me when you say I love you again
and again and again what you are
definitely doing regardless of the
feeling is reaffirming that decision
that you are you have decided to be and
I know that sounds kind of unromantic
and I apologize but I think that like
parts of love are parts of romantic love
are super romantic and parts of romantic
love are not and I think that's okay so
yeah I don't know what that noise was
but please meet you from that as glad as
all I had to say and I'm gonna let
Hank's phone take it from here
I like that I asked you to be your phone
and then the first thing you did was
make your phone make another day I
didn't make it make a noise you're like
oh I know how to make it make a
different noise I didn't cancel no
texting me he's I I have like 15 minutes
to finish this well it's gonna take
longer than that okay well it isn't I'm
going to make you leave this next
question comes from Kenya who asks dear
Hank and John what do you think would be
the best food to build a house out of
considering structural integrity
verifiable
considering structural integrity
livability and environment this question
came up on a road trip and since we
couldn't agree on the best answer we're
asking you no I can't
Kenya oh my got it yeah yeah it took me
a second to think yeah yeah okay hit me
I've thought about this a lot I have as
well peanut M&Ms no
oh well I mean the thing like
gingerbread houses seem to last a long
time yeah but that is not an edible food
gingerbread houses are edible food I
mean if you are extremely highly
motivated maybe if you are experiencing
some kind of like if you're over
hydrated and you need something to dry
out your mouth I drink too much water
okay I like a gingerbread cookie but
nobody likes a gingerbread house no well
I mean little bits of it you're right
you're right but like but this isn't
like this is what food and that's food
but but but wait for this one okay what
animal is it food for is it food for a
beaver would Bob build your house out of
wood
those your house out of wood because
it's beaver food that's good or build
your house out of bricks because
everybody knows that unicorns eat bricks
yeah maybe or you'd build your house out
of what if you build your house out of
glass and steel because that's a
wonderful meal if you're gently
engineered microorganism that is
genetically engineered to eat glass and
steel that's a good Hank that's nice and
tight okay it's we're very tired and
I've been on the road together for like
13 days never been this tired I have
been this time I am Allah the the bus
sleeping has made me quite sore I
my back hurts a limping on the bus is
one of the least fun sleeps I've ever
had there's up there's a number of pains
that I didn't really expect I also there
is a noise in the back in the back four
bunks there is a noise you know that
knowing have you heard that noise no no
no no there's a constant like banging
noise that is at first it's like oh
that's a pretty that's oh that's a soft
noise it sounds almost like just like a
little drum just like a little drum beat
and then like one hour into trying to go
to sleep you're like that is actually
the loudest noise that has ever
happen and it isn't like a little
drumbeat because it's just random enough
to make my brain not be able to calm
down so here Hank and I are complaining
about our very fancy tool buck and the
poor quality of sleep that we get on it
oh my god Wow we're an embarrassment we
are this question comes from Liam who
writes dear green brothers my boyfriend
who I love dearly has recently taken a
political stance I find troubling well
what is the political stance oh he says
some people from our school wanna start
a conservative Club but he's currently
trying to get the club banned because he
doesn't want to give them the platform I
don't think that just because somebody
disagrees with my values they shouldn't
be a lot of space to discuss their
opinions I just don't really know what
to say to him because it's weird and I
don't want to be rude Liam well
disagreeing isn't necessarily being rude
yeah I think that like you gotta have a
relationship with people and you're
gonna have differences of opinion right
when you love each other you're going to
disagree and you're going to have to
learn how to respectfully listen and
also sometimes like disagree in an
ongoing way sometimes I worry if I agree
too much with a person because I think
they're just trying to avoid conflict
right and I'm like well but do you
really think all of the things that I
think and it's and I like yeah cuz I
don't I don't but you have to be your
own people and that means that you're
gonna have moments where and it's okay
to disagree and like and to have those
conversations and to come out of it not
having come to a conclusion where you're
both on the same page although I have to
say Hank that I feel like you and I when
we disagree I don't want to generalize
but every time we've disagreed in the
last like year or so six weeks after our
disagreement call me and you say you
were right all along it's happened it
has happened a non-save Rhys Engle
disagreement we've had because I don't
keep a list I mean I'll be like I'm
pretty sure that the social Internet is
bad for the social order and Hank will
be like that's ridiculous how could you
make
that's not what I thought that's not
what I said but I have come around to
your perspective yeah okay that's that's
how I feel about this situation this
year she comes from Jayden who says you
have to learn to love each other and
disagree and productively Jaden says
Dear John and Hank if you find one sock
in the dryer do you have an extra sock
or a missing saw and that's a great way
to think about it because like obviously
you have a missing sock because it's not
like you didn't have the socks before
right you had the socks and then one
disappeared probably unless you have a
new sock in which is in many ways more
upsetting it's more disturbing if your
washing machine or dryer is creating
socks from the materials that you do the
first like that's goods concern to me
just like official intelligence has
gotten too good yeah like really like
the lint drawer like popped out and it
was like you know I've got enough for a
argyle cotton one it's gonna have some
elastic bits - boy I tell you what this
is not how entropy works I 3d printed
this sock for you and then put it in the
back of myself thank you for drawing
with me I yeah I put your favorite
slogan on it it says memento mori
available at DVD it's not it's not yet
it's not um I like this idea though
because I never thought of losing a sock
as a glass-half-full situation right at
least I didn't lose both socks but it
kind of is yeah if I ever got that I've
got the sock now and now and then you
can like I think you can do some cool
things with unmatching so what do you
think yeah what do you think about just
not wearing matching socks so I did that
for many years I wore mismatching Argyle
intentionally almost every day
intentionally and I wish I could say
like in my teens but like in my early
thirties
mismatching argyle socks intentionally
most days and it solved some problems
and it created others what I found in
more recently in my life is that I will
wear mismatching socks when I have
singles mm-hmm but I like pairing my
socks for a variety of reasons I just
think it makes everyone's life a little
bit easier both for a laundry and for
right yeah getting dressed in the
morning that way I don't have to like
double the amount of time I spend
thinking about socks like what would go
with this purple Argyle sock instead of
being like green or red I could just be
like Oh her pur purple Argyle sock so
here's the thing that I did not until my
30s do yeah which is I have a separate
spot for the singles because what
happens is like if I do a load of
laundry
what my it might not be that I lost the
sock I might just be in the next one and
then like but like if I could I've got
this sock I just throw it in with the
other socks so I can like an unpaired
sock with the pair of socks and who like
when that other sock shows back up it
might be the next day it might be three
weeks from now but if I put the singles
in a separate spot and then like I can
go through that every once in a while
and be like okay this single has been
sitting here unmatched I can get rid of
that or turn it into a dish rag or
something don't wash your dishes with a
foot very bad foot holder don't do that
that's that's a place where your stink
but but foot goes said stink but foot
high quality podcast it's real good yeah
you get what I'm saying I totally do
let's move don't have can I explain it
more fully please don't I think we're
all why didn't we all got there this
question comes from Eleanor he writes
dear brothers green my beloved collie is
the light of my life I love him like the
Seas love the moon I'm worried about
where this is gonna go however I know
because every time we get a question and
the first sentence is about the dog by
the end of the email the dog is dead or
or like what should we do about my dying
dog right and I make like I mean I think
I'm stressed out enough
dying dog I can't deal with yours
however he is very frightened to the
toaster Oh things have taken a positive
job good I mean he's great news Eleanor
your collie is fine every time we try to
make toast he holds on to one of his
toys like a security blanket starts
whining and barking and totally
de-stressed that is sad I am tried
shutting him out of the kitchen
distracting him shashi and fussing over
him but so far no luck I would give up
toast if I had to but if you provide a
possible solution I'd be very grateful
as I do like toast all right he signs
off lupus canis toaster which Google
translates to toaster is a wolf to dog
Eleanor Eleanor that is fantastic it's a
fantastic email all around you also sent
a very cute picture your border collie
looking very distressed I mean okay I'm
gonna say it
toasters are stressful toasters are
stressful that's not how come I have
been toasting my whole life and yet
still when the toast pops out the
toaster on my cool like as if a man has
broken into my house with an axe is how
I feel I cannot just make an observation
before you move on with this question
mm-hmm I feel like right now we just did
this show in front of 1100 people and I
feel like this is a great example of the
difference between Hank and me because
Hank has so much energy right now like
he is like bursting with energy there's
a man with an ax in his house and the
toaster and it's great and I feel like I
have been drained of all of my lifeblood
I feel like I was like John you want to
go pod I feel like Voldemort just drank
all of my unicorn blood and now I'm
trying to like stagger out of the
Forbidden Forest and Hanks like enough
data give me a break
Eleanor I have great news I have a
solution to this problem hmm
don't toast your toast in the toaster
man where should i toast at the
microwave
I disappointed in you
that's not toasting that's hotting yeah
you just get you just get gluttonous
squishy miss it's very warm and it's
very soggy and it's delicious you just
okay it's not toast it's uh warm bread
correct
as I read I'm on paid what about the
oven what about the oven can do it you
could do it you could also get a toaster
oven which is I think much less
terrified until makes that like it still
has that countdown which is a little
stressful and then it's like yeah you
can just stop in my experiment because I
mean now I'm gonna sound weird but like
ah I don't there I don't like toaster
ovens with their with the Bing I'm fine
with it
as a reminder but I don't want it to be
a requirement to acquire toast right
well is it toaster oven that you can
just turn off without the banging yeah
yeah I mean most toaster ovens have the
ability to be a little oven and you just
like set it to fourth yeah and you toast
it was twenty bucks though Eleanor and I
don't know what your budget is for
toaster ovens but that seems like the
easiest solution and then the second
solution would just be to microwave your
bread and turn it into like a hot nasty
soggy bog embroidery goo ball yeah yeah
actually now that I've set the phrase
buttery goo ball I actually kind of want
a one this podcast
by the way brought to you by buttery goo
balls yep buttery goo ball bran buttery
goo balls available wherever buttery goo
balls are sold this podcast is also
brought to you by accidentally sending a
voice memo to somebody you have a crush
on are you accidentally sending a voice
memo to somebody you have a crush on
just run away and just yeah everything
will be fine but not for like seven
years this podcast is also brought to
you by the air in your study which is
now 97% candle wax and lastly this
podcast is brought to you by Jameson
school Jameson school starting at 7:00
[Music]
no good all right hey guys answer a
couple more questions from our listeners
before we get to the all-important news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon like tipped
away the news from Mars and a super
woman live as long as possible this
question comes from Mickey who asks dear
brothers green I have a fear that some
may consider irrational I am scared of
Elon Musk he just seems like the guy in
every movie that you suspect to be the
main villain as soon as they walk on
screen
there's something very Lex Luthor ian's
about him and freaks me out
perhaps this whole rich guy who wants to
explore space thing I don't trust it PS
I'm not convinced you two are completely
trustworthy either I'm so fine I may
blow your mind Mickey no that's a good
one Mickey I also don't have a ton of
trust in us Mickey here's the thing I
think it makes sense to be distrustful
of people who benefit from existing
power structures because they will
always be biased by how much they've
benefited from those power structures
that is a good that is a good point I
also think that it is good to be a
little bit suspicious of billionaires
because that's a lot of money and you
don't get all of it by being nice I will
say that probably there are a lot of
billionaires that we don't hear about
that we should be more suspicious of yes
I actually am less suspicious of Elon
Musk than I am because at least Lee is
like a public like I know that
billionaire billionaire
yeah those billionaires are very quiet
about it doing things behind the scenes
they like they have timeshare companies
and stuff I I think what's a timeshare
company do you really want me to get
into the business of timeshares when I'm
so tired I feel like I might die at any
moment
can you give me a update on the plateau
Hotel Transylvania behind me the Hotel
Transylvania there's bat and there's a
sowing I believe we've entered the
beginning of act 3
I think things got as bad as they could
get and now this invisible thing with
glasses is putting on its makeup and
it's very charming ok
so to move back to the question I don't
think there's anything please stop
watching Hotel Transylvania we have to
end this podcast bond I so I I think
when you have a lot a lot a lot of
resources people should be a little
suspicious of you they should hold you
to a high standard and like the same
thing when you have a lot a lot a lot of
power yeah I also like I kind of worry
about Elon Musk's health like he seems
to be going hard he's a hard charger but
I mean some people want it look you only
get one ride on this carousel and some
people really want to suck the marrow
out of life I'm not one of them but some
people do that's for a nibble around the
edges of life I'm not a marrow guy yeah
you know like you know like like hitting
life with a rock to get at that last
calorie no yeah no III only like the
very precious cuts of meat yeah what
well just take the good yeah just the
define define this metaphor is not great
it's led to a troubling situation I
don't like it we're both suspicious of
Elon Musk but I also have to say I
really like a lot of what Elon Musk is
doing and I think that he's a
fascinating person and I have to say
overall I am glad that he is in the
world and I I do wish him well and I
wish you much success because we need
people especially when it comes to
responsible energy usage and figuring
out yeah like sustainable energy
solutions we need the smartest people on
those problems and Elon Musk is on that
problem unlike most of the smartest
people who are you know selling
timeshares or whatever getting making
billions via all Marting doing Walmart
Inc being the third-generation Walmart
yeah where you know airs aren't turning
money into more money through money
that's questionable money instruments
it's my favorite line uh Jonathan
Within's novel chronic City one of the
characters describes his job as moving
the pile of money around trying to make
it bigger
it's it's it's it's works um but I do
worry about the long-term sustainability
of just rolling rolling the money ball
it has it sticks to more and more money
but with money so John yes what is the
news from AFC Wimbledon the news from
AFC Wimbledon it was since we last
pondered Hank there was this huge spurt
of Hope AFC Wimbledon won two games in a
row scoring a total of four goals in
those two games which nearly doubled
their number of goals for the entire
season this is good things were looking
good but then then then AFC Wimbledon
played Plymouth Argyle who were in the
very basement of Ligue 1 though there
were they're doing even worse than AFC
Wimbledon s and lost as a home game Oh
God and we lost a Plymouth Argyle one
nil and this means that now after 15
games AFC Wimbledon have accrued 15
points that is probably not a pace that
is good enough to not get relegated we
will probably have to improve the number
of points per game above 1 yeah not get
relegated so so you have to start
winning some games winning or tying ok
but winning would be even better
yes just stop losing would be great stop
losing you know it'd be great goals
goals Hank has scored eight goals eight
goals in what games 16 eight goals in 15
games that's like that's not great it's
not a lot of goals I'm sorry to hear
this situation about a symbol and goals
thank you that Mars yes so NASA has just
discovered a weird weird thing about
Mars so as you know Mars does not have a
magnetic field right but doesn't have a
strong magnetic field but it turns out
it does have something of a magnetic
field so it's magnetic field shut down a
long time ago but there is some residual
magnetic field and
I'm not entirely clear on where that's
coming from if it's like permanent
dipoles left over from like the
inducement of the old magnetic field or
if there's just still some stuff moving
around inside of it which it seems like
there might still be a little bit of
volcanic activity maybe down in the in
the depth there though certainly nothing
that would do make the kind of magnetic
field that the the earth has but weird
thing Mars it turns out in the way that
like this weak magnetic field interferes
with the solar wind is create it with
these like high-energy particles being
pushed out by the Sun is creating this
weird magnetic tail like rather than a
magnetic sphere around the planet it's
like this tail thing as Mars is a comet
and the magnets like I know there's a
tail yeah it's like it's weird cuz I as
it travels around the Sun it's leaving
this tail behind they it's it is
apparently according to Gino de Braccio
of NASA's Goddard spike Goddard Space
Flight Center it's unique in the solar
system just calling it a magnetotail
just because that sounds good that
sounds great yeah and it may be that
this this tail actually had something to
do with the mechanism of how the
atmosphere of Mars was stripped away so
all this the gases that may be just like
evaporated water carbon dioxide that was
once around the planet has been pushed
off they think this might have something
to do with that which is part of why
it's hard place to be to live yeah Wow I
mean that just makes me think that
someday our magnetic field might turn
into a magnetic tail and then everyone
will be like was there ever life on this
planet probably not now they'll be able
to see the stuff will then I mean for a
while thanks for listening
dear Hank and John truly a comedy
podcast about death um this was great
fun Polly with you Hank I'm so - no I'm
sorry I made you do this I was fun I'm
so tired though
thank you for listening we're not gonna
record this week in Ryan's no we aren't
we barely have enough to record this
podcast this is why it's so short yeah
guys but we will we'll be back next week
with both this weekend Ryan's and a full
just brilliant episode are gonna hit it
out of the park everything that this
wasn't that will be this podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson it's edited by nicholas
jenkins our theme music is by the great
granola our community and communications
manager is the torah bon giorno and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]